I'm gonna go take another crack At
Whitman give me
give me the times what are you gonna do
to talking ha ha
ha two three four
[Music]
[Applause]
didn't work
Q did not work well I guess we did just
spend 48 Hours locked in here together
holy crap what locked in here together
so we will be filing a wrongful arrest
suit against the NYPD
and when I win I'm gonna buy Club torque
put a statue of Jake Peralta right in
the middle of dance floor first off
that's a terrible threat I would love to
have a statue of myself in the middle of
a dance club second do me a favor take a
look at this picture and tell me what
you see
[Music]
it's Philbin awesome right surprisingly
down to earth guy and definitely not the
picture I meant to show you but take a
look at this
that's right it's you and your old
cellmate Marcus Cole and here he is
again outside the jewelry store the two
of you planned this together in prison
you taught him your ammo he pulled off
the robbery you got yourself an alibi
and you split the loot oh man I can't
believe he caught us of course he did
Peralta is the best ah thanks rege
that's enough yeah I gotta work on my
Regis anyway see you in jail Whitman I
guess that's your new best friend now
Santiago emphasis on Iago backstabber
I'm surprised you've read Othello what
the hell's a fellow I'm calling you the
parrot from Aladdin guys
my water just broke
don't worry about that we'll just get
you another one Oh you mean your body
water that's much worse I really wish
you'd show up I gotta go to the bathroom
so bad it's like the third time today
man what is going on with you oh Amy
freaked out because I told her I never
drink water so now she's making me drink
eight glasses a day it's like there's
water and soda there's water and coffee
there's little pools of water on pizza
that's grease Jake what's wet isn't it
okay
ah y'all ready for this you know what
I'm saying Terry Jeffords allow me to
introduce to you
our murder victim the not dead Nate
Dexter
what the hell is going on
right Sophia wasn't lying I was just not
asking the right questions she hadn't
seen her husband in eight years but she
was positive there's no way that he
killed Dexter that's when it occurred to
me no one killed him
hey Nate just talking about how you're
alive yeah I'm alive but who's melted
torso did we find
thank you
Sophia's husband yes Sophia and Dexter
were having an affair husband found out
Nate killed him now I'm telling my
friend about how you killed that guy it
was for love cool motive still murder
also you remember that severed finger
check this out hey Nate show us your
hands please
right cut it off himself how screwed up
is that anyway I asked all my CIS if
they had dealings with a nine-fingered
man unsolvable case
solved whoa this is so unfair I've lived
in this building 15 years and then all
of a sudden they decide they're going
co-op with zero warning it seems illegal
they didn't tell you this was happening
well it's possible I missed a letter but
I doubt it oh let's check the mail tab
mail tub nope no no
see it's impossible to find anything in
here it's not my fault detective we'd
like you to go undercover and help us
with the investigation okay the answer
is yes the details are my name is Duncan
Buck I was raised on an oil rig by 90
men and one prostitute we'd like you to
be yourself even better this could be
very dangerous so please take some time
I'm in eyes closed head first can't lose
I don't think that's the expression can
you just let me have
a vision well this woman wait Amy shut
up excuse me I mean I'm so sorry you
were making a totally valid point about
gender equality but I just thought of
something really important so I'm gonna
hang up on you okay love you bye
it wasn't Russo or his sons
it was the daughter
hello everyone guess who just solved a
20 year old unsolvable case wait what
you guys figured out who pulled the
first Sussex Bank Job yeah
we realized we never checked the
daughter's Alibi she wasn't at the
softball trip she had access to the
plants and then she just confessed
that's right we arrested a woman today
because we are feminists we must solve
one of Vin's puzzles to enter rearrange
the letters of this phrase to reveal a
place in the world meet a brainier stud
a oh come on there's no place with that
many letters in it most places are like
four letters you know Park Mall dump
United Arab Emirates mantor
uh you must each answer a puzzle oh
great unscramble the letters in this
phrase to reveal the name of the film
based on a classic novel okay sad anus
loser I go in you know I feel like these
puzzles are actually very pointed forget
it I got this uh
puzzle solved Amy's parents look down on
me they talk about me right in front of
my face in Spanish because they don't
think I'm smart enough to learn another
language but I've been taking classes
and now I can understand all the hurtful
things they've been saying and how did
that help well now I know they think I'm
short and I was able to do some research
and find that 1940 census that proves
I'm above average in height for 1940.
yeah I'm taller than the greatest
Generation it doesn't matter I told you
not to lie what were you thinking I
thought it would work and I wanted to be
the one that got him this was about your
ego are you that desperate for everyone
to know how great you are it's not about
everyone okay it's just
I wanted you to know
oh my God
I got it
he's not answering any questions that's
okay I have no questions that's right
I'm about to monologue son better make
it quick you only got eight minutes all
right then let me paint you a picture
I'm Phillip a successful periodontist
that's become addicted to diazepam has
said it if I take because I'm junkie
scum also for real addiction is a
disease I would be super empathetic if
you hadn't murdered a man what is the
point of this I'll get there so one day
I'm working late when my boss Robert
surprises me he found out I was stealing
meds again junkie's gone also again not
your fault there's a major genetic
component to addiction he says he's
going to file a police report I could
lose my license we fight and something
in me just snaps so I grab the first
thing I can find and I hit him with it
you still have no mortar weapon I do now
here's a pic I found on Yelp of the
surgical Suite six months ago and here's
a shot that our crime scene photographer
took up the same room two weeks after
the murder notice any differences we're
not answering that that's all right I
can just tell you myself the Yelp shot
has six of these heavy Looking Glass
awards from the Brooklyn periodontics
Society in the background whereas this
shot only has five what happened to
number six you murdered Robert with him
you lost all control and you bludgeoned
him to death there must have been blood
but you got lucky you were in the
surgical Suite it can be sterilized you
never would have gotten away with it in
your carpeted office that's not what
happened don't say anything more and
your office manager would have heard all
of the screaming but she was at her
grandson's play lucky again you're wrong
you put Robert's body into a wheelchair
and shoved it in the elevator it's a
miracle there wasn't blood everywhere
that's not true now you're in the garage
with a corpse you panicked and left your
phone in your office and you don't have
your car keys but Roberts are in his
pocket so he put him in his car and you
take off you can't believe what you've
done no you're flustered you have no GPS
so you just start driving no next thing
you know you're in the Pine Barrens and
it hits you your uncle's cabin he has a
place there you're the luckiest son yes
it was you got lucky at every turn I
knew exactly where I was driving I left
my phone in the office on purpose I was
in a surgical Suite by Design and I
didn't use some glass award that any
idiot would clearly see was missing I
made a rod out of a special dental
polymer killed him with it then melted
it back down it's already in a patient's
mouth son
oh damn oh damn oh damn and that is 3-0
dams oh damn
oh
fresh air
well I don't say that a lot there's one
thing I still don't understand
did you know you had the wrong murder
weapon oh excellent question sir yes I
spotted the missing Dental award when I
first took the case I asked around weeks
ago turns out a cleaning lady knocked it
over and shattered it then why did you
run in there like that because in
talking to you I realized what Philip's
worst fear actually was that we would
think he was just some dummy that got
lucky right he had planned the perfect
crime and it killed him when you said he
was sloppy and impulsive he needed us to
know how smart he was hi
like someone else I know
yep
Kevin
I'm probably
thank you sir
no let's go get some sleep hey guys
my goodness we're almost late for word
oh well in that case
good morning sir good morning
[Music]
foreign